welcome back including you Jamie
bet you miss hearing that huh
[Laughter]
my goodness what's wrong with me you're
looking more like Sam Harris every day
by the way I really noticed that okay
enough of this banter
two years after Biden won cbs's laptop
report is done yes it took that long for
the CBS sleuths to finally admit the
truth
more than two years after the New York
Post broke the hunter Biden laptop story
and got booted for it from pre-elon
Twitter CBS News finally confirmed it's
real in an earth-shattering bombshell
report yesterday
two years late just like Hunter Biden's
child support
roll it Dede the laptop data we had
analyzed showed no evidence it was faked
or tampered with you're confident based
on your analysis this is Hunter Biden's
data and that it's real yes
I have to give you guys credit once you
get a hold of a story you know you're
relentless
I wonder if you guys are helping OJ
search for the real killers
get on top of that but please go on CBS
News lanterman and his son Sean both
digital forensic experts recovered
images of credit cards a driver's
license social security number just the
sheer volume of what we're dealing with
it would be difficult uh if not
impossible to fabricate oh that's more
than enough to ID its owner plus there
was so much of Hunter's DNA three of the
investigators got pregnant
and they were men
what's so funny that that can happen now
that can happen so in summary CBS News
is reporting what you already knew to be
true for more than two years but the
media had an election to influence so
the laptop vanished like Hunter facing a
paternity test
but hey good for CBS I'm looking forward
to them covering the assassination of
President Abraham Lincoln
I believe they consider John Wilkes
Booth a person of interest
Jimmy when you see this doesn't this
make you want to pull out what's left of
your hair oh my gosh I know well
it's amazing your head's getting bigger
right yeah my head's just massive the
worst part is my husband this big since
the day I was born like for real I'm
pretty sure this is why my dad left
[Laughter]
there are reasons for that that I won't
get into it but uh no it's crazy it's
amazing to think it took them two years
to complete an investigation but it took
them two days to complete a Twitter
boycott yeah you know what I mean like
really it turns out CBS stands for
complete
that's what it stands for
I did not see that one coming I don't
know obviously right but the truth is as
you know the only reason anyone's
reporting on this is because Republicans
won the house and this story is going to
be thoroughly vetted and it's going to
see the light of day and they want to
put some distance between themselves and
what they did before the election and
what's going on now because they look
very bad for knowingly covering it up
because one thing that needs to be said
is they didn't authenticate this based
on new information there is no new
information the same information we had
in October of 2020. so the reason people
want it looked into and it should be
looked into is he is not Hunter Biden
getting this money if his dad's not the
vice president of the United States
there's no way around that no one was
sitting well thank you I wasn't sure I
wasn't going for that but no one is
sitting on the board of a power company
going you know what we need on the board
we need a drug addict that's really
flaky okay we know that wasn't the goal
they would have called me and Cat bottom
line would have saved the money see I
roped you into that yeah thanks
I don't get enough of that without you
[Laughter]
so cat uh what do you think it took CBS
News so long and do you have some sort
of analogy that might best explain it
I I don't think it did take them that
long I don't know why they're just
coming I mean I guess good for them for
coming out with it now
I guess but if I'm ever in trouble I
definitely want them to be the ones
investigating me
like if that's how investigations into
the past go I could run for office after
all yeah
um everybody knew yeah even Hunter never
said that's not mine yes he said I don't
know which if you look at the contents
of the laptop sounds like exactly what
whoever owned it would say yes exactly
he only says that's not mine he was like
when he's talking about the babies
that's true it is true I don't even
think do you think Joe's seen his
grandson or is it grandson or
granddaughter I don't think he knows
about it yeah I don't I just I don't
know why knowing all that stuff was on
how could you not have time to go pick
it up especially when you're smoking
that much crack he also says yeah
there's another one yeah the meth would
keep you up I'd be like okay I'm gonna
go pick up I can't wait to pick up that
laptop I'm so high you're awake for you
you're awake for like 90 hours one of
those go pick it up exactly what else
can you wait don't stop on your way to
get more crack there's only so many
[ __ ] you can bang Hunter
up your laptop
hey think about it I mean think about
how much how many problems are going to
solved if he just did one errand one
Aaron one errand he was one errand away
from being super rich
so uh Jamie um
how's the Alaska press handling this
story
we're just we're just about to get one
yeah we're getting a press you're right
about 100 I feel like if we turned in
Hunter Biden's pillowcase we'd saw three
cold cases
foreign
I heard that he thought they wouldn't be
able to get into the light you know they
couldn't get into the laptop but it had
facial recognition protection on there
so anyone with a crack pipe in their
mouth yeah I could open it I don't know
man I think he's I don't think he's as
abnormal as I think he's kind of like a
regular guy I think when he goes into
the backyard he takes his pants off one
leg at a time just like the rest of us
[Music]
Michelle what do you make of this story
I I was looking for the breaking news
Banner on this story you know but I
think they got scooped on this one and
I'm just wondering you know were those
guys in Minneapolis where they were they
just now free to analyze this laptop I
mean is that what they were waiting for
the guys in Minneapolis this this is so
not about Hunter though you know I mean
even though it is it's so much more
about Joe the big guy and all of this
stuff that seems to be so provable and
look the way he treats China the way
that Joe Biden handles China
leads me to believe there may be some he
may be compromised he is so easy on them
and you know this latest um thing oh
we'll all give a billion dollars to
these countries but China doesn't have
to because they're still developing I
mean what in the hell in the hell but so
I I don't mean because I agree with you
that he looks compromised yeah but Biden
thinks China is something that Jill puts
out when companies coming well that's a
good point that's a good point I don't
think I've ever seen CBS so careful
about a story let's not forget they did
60 minutes which was not about it was
about preparing to attack somebody yes
it was Ambush journalism it wasn't like
let's let's be really careful no it was
like let's wait behind their garage door
and jump on them remember when Leslie
Stahl sat down with Trump and he said
you're not investigating this laptop she
said it can't be verified it can't be
verified yeah and that was what two
years ago so now suddenly as you said
just in time for the story to become
real investigations they finally
verified I tell you what Dan Rather must
be spinning in his grave
no one got it I got it
yeah I'm not going to do a correction
[Laughter]
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else